il y avait foule dans les rues de
guayaquil depuis ce mercredi cette ville
portuaire épicentre de la pandémie de
coronavirus dans le pays a assoupli
certaines mesures de restriction fini le
couvre-feu de 15 heures par jours
instaurée depuis neuf semaines
il est dorénavant limitée entre 21h et
5h du matin fini aussi le télétravail
obligatoire le travail présentiel étant
désormais autorisées mais limitées à 50
% du personnel les transports publics
urbains et les activités commerciales
eux sont rétablis tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut sortir
tout le monde mais seulement par
nécessité mais nous sommes tous inquiets
de la trappe et ça c'est sûr nous sommes
tous inquiets mais on doit sortir pour
acheter du pain
de toute façon le gouvernement ne nous
aide pas ils nous oublient un sentiment
d'abandon partagé par de nombreux
équatorien comme ces familles de
victimes qui manifestent devant le
tribunal de la ville sans nouvelles du
corps de leur proche mort du co vie 19
elles ont décidé d'attaquer l'état
équatorien mon père est mort le 1er
avril les médecins légistes sont venus
le chercher le lendemain il devait
m'appeler mais ils ne l'ont pas fait
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
depuis on essaye de savoir pourquoi et
ils ne disent rien sur mon père
il n'y a eu aucune réponse de la
présidence de la république ni du comité
des opérations d'urgence
ils ont éludé leurs responsabilités et
cela les rend coupable de toutes les
actions que nous allons prendre des
familles de victimes qui doivent
également faire face aux dettes de
plusieurs milliers de dollars contracté
par leurs proches
les hôpitaux publics submergé
l'assistance médicale privée souvent la
seule option pour les malades du
coronavirus une option coûteuse entre
400 à 800 dollars par journées
d'hospitalisation et entre 1500 et 2500
dollars en soins intensifs
alors que le salaire minimum en équateur
ne dépasse pas les 400 dollars par mois